jetzt ist es ja auch bei dem täter der
fall deshalb psychisch ich sag mal eine
vorgeschichte eine vorbelastung hatte
wie sehr trägt das dazu bei dass so eine
tat von der idee umgesetzt wird so zu
sagen ja es sind zwei dinge die sich
keineswegs ausschließen und teilweise
sogar gegenseitig befruchten um das
profil ein bisschen schärfer zu ziehen
wenn man sich die ganzen letzten taten
anschaut und die taten auf
gemeinsamkeiten analysiert muss man
schon objektiv feststellen dass es
welche gibt erst einmal sind es männer
das meine ich gar nicht werden es aber
erstmal eine objektive feststellung des
amok und terrorismus primär männliche
phänomene sind ich muss mir im leben
nicht anzubieten warum das so ist wird
in der kriminologie lange diskutiert ist
aber erst mal so es sind aber keine
kinder hat auch keine rentner das heißt
man kann auch das alter etwas zumindest
eingrenzen und kann sagen dass zwischen
18 und 30 also junge männer eine gruppe
zu sein scheinen bei denen das besonders
häufig ist aber sind es normale junge
männer zwischen 18 und 30 oder gibt es
noch andere besonderheiten die sie
auszeichnen die gibt es durchaus die
ideologie ist übrigens keine große
übereinstimmung ich weiß zwar dass die
anschläge immer wieder probiert werden
zu instrumentalisieren wenn die polizei
gerade in so einem fall wo es eine um
einen irakischen staatsbürger geht wenn
die polizei sagt das ist terror dann
kommt der vorwurf von links und dh das
ist rachel profiligen erster deutscher
würden wir von absprechen
und wenn die polizei von amok spricht
kommt der vorwurf von rechts und das
heißt fake news manipulierte medien die
kerns unter den tisch sie wollen das
wieder nicht beim namen nennen oder was
auch immer das heißt egal was die
polizei sagt es gibt immer ärger aus der
ein oder anderen ecke es ist aber sehr
schwierig bei diese grenzen verschwimmen
und es sind junge männer aber es gibt
weitere zutaten die dazukommen
es sind junge männer mit kürzlichen
rückschlägen mit kränkungen mit
misserfolgen selten bis nie eigentlich
nie ist mir eine meldung bekannt wo es
heißt glücklich verheiratete
familienvater mit zwei kindern
erfolgreich im job finanziell alles
läuft wollte sich gerade ein haus bauen
und hat jetzt ein attentat verübt
passiert nicht das heißt es sind junge
männer die der fachausdruck ist
psychosoziale isoliert keine freundin
keine freunde keine freundinnen das
verhältnis zu frauen wird maßgeblich
unterschätzt bei vielen attentaten
oftmals kommt noch narzissmus dazu das
heißt personen die sich eigentlich
großartig finden selbst
aber es darf keinen wege bestätigen
kriegen weder bei frauen noch job noch
bei freunden noch auf der arbeit sind
nicht so richtig erfolgreich und die
größte angst eines narzissten ganz
wichtiger satz ist es nicht unbeliebt zu
sein sondern unbedeutend zu sein
märtyrer zu sein es ihnen immer noch
lieber als ein niemand zu sein und ich
habe auch ein bisschen schwierigkeiten
mit dem begriff einzeltäter denn
kriminalität passiert nie im luftleeren
raum
es gibt immer auch wenn es keine
direkten mit planer oder mittäter gibt
gibt es immer ein umfeld familie freunde
online eine online community und täter
wissen sehr genau dass sie in bestimmten
kreisen für bestimmte taten anerkennung
bekommen und als märtyrer gefeiert
werden
und das ist kein unwesentlicher teil der
motivation deswegen einzeltäter jahr
aber möglicherweise aber kriminalität
passiert trotzdem nicht im luftleeren
raum
aber junge frustrierte männer mit
manchmal noch psychischen erkrankungen
und oder narzissmus was ich noch
abgrenzen würde junge frustrierte männer
mit narzisstischen zügen oder
erkrankungen sind eine exklusive eine
gefährliche mischung die immer wieder zu
schlimmen gewalttaten geführt hat der
eine sagt dann die frauen sind schuld
und tötet frauen da der andere sagt die
ungläubigen sind schuld und der nächste
sagt die ausländer sind schuld das heißt
die ideologie ist fast austauschbar
aber es hat immer auch was mit den
persönlichen motiven zu tun denn ich
will es mal so formulieren für einen
versager und ich benutze ruhig mal das
wort oder für jemanden der im leben in
keiner dimensionen das erreicht hat was
er erreichen wollte sein möglicherweise
nazismus nicht stillen konnte für diese
personen sind radikale ideologien das
ist musik in den ohren wenn wir beide
ein radikales video sehen würden dann
würde dieses sogenannte gift wie die
kanzlerin ist mal beschrieben hat er
diesmal über rassismus gesagt rassismus
ist ein gift was die gedanken vergiftet
uns beide wird es möglicherweise nicht
vergiften weil wenn man glücklich und
gefestigt ist verfängt das nicht aber
wenn sie unzufrieden frustriert wütend
sind dann gibt ideologie der wut eine
richtung das vielleicht ein ganz guter
satz ideologie gibt wut richtung aber
oft ist die wut schon vorher da die wut
ist aber ungerichtete es ist einfach ein
frustrierter mann und dann kommt eine
ideologie daher die sagt die frauen sind
schuld oder die ausländer sind schuld
oder die ungläubigen sind schuld und das
ist für diese täter für täter mit diesem
profil dass das musik in den ohren denn
das
gibt ihnen die chance eine gruppe von
schuldigen zu identifizieren
psychologisch ist es dass
externalisierung von misserfolgen es ist
immer gut oder immer schön zu sagen für
erfolge sind wir gern selbst
verantwortlich wenn die eigene
fußballmannschaft gewinnt sagen leute
wir haben gewonnen wenn die eigene
fußballmannschaft verliert sagen sie sie
haben verloren
das heißt wir probieren uns mit erfolgen
zu identifizieren und misserfolge dafür
sind natürlich andere verantwortlich
niemals sind schüler dummen eltern sagen
immer er ist nur faul
was auch nicht immer war es das heißt
wir neigen dazu ganz allgemein
misserfolge anderen zuzuschieben und
leider gilt das auch für kriminalität
eine gruppe von schuldigen das ist ja
das was alle radikale aller radikalen
ideologien gemeinsam haben es gibt eine
gruppe von schuldigen die ich für mein
eigenes versagen verantwortlich machen
kann und es würde mich nicht wundern
wenn das auch in diesem fall eine ganz
maßgebliche rolle gespielt hat